Mitt Romney posted this video a few days
ago well as you all know today is
National Hot Dog Day and perhaps you
also know that hot dog is my favorite
meat I love hot dogs I love them in buns
I love them outside of buns I love them
with baked beans I just like hot dogs
it's the best you know best meat there
is without question did you catch the
problem though there's always something
with this guy and here's the problem
ketchup he's got ketchup on the hot dog
no person over the age of 18. really no
person over the age of 14 or 15 should
ever put ketchup on a hot dog it
destroys the delicious taste and flavor
and complexities of the hot dog a hot
dog is meant to be enjoyed with chopped
onions I need sauerkraut on a hot dog
mustard but not ketchup ketchup is for
little children